so
can we talk about a couple things that
just came up with uh let's
let's stay on that miami thing because
silicon valley elites are moving
to miami but vc's told the mayor that a
state law needs to change
before they would relocate so we talked
about earlier companies from new york
relocating to miami right we're talking
about goldman sachs carl icahn some of
those guys right
and one of them moved into uh uh palm
beach the 41 billion dollar
uh uh uh hedge fund what's his name uh
carl
paul singer no no paul singer 41 billion
dollars moving his stuff to
uh palm beach but here's an issue with
miami and miami mayor you've interviewed
you've been involved mayor francis the
mayor of miami spent at least
least part of the weekend on twitter
trying to convince silicon valley tech
workers
and investors to hang up their fleece
vests and move to south florida's
uh a growing tech hub text migration to
miami has been happening for a while now
that while reddit co-founder alexis
ohanian making the move to south florida
a few
years ago but it's picked up steam as
more people work from home particularly
during the pandemic but even as tech
investors
depart from miami full on migration
hinges on the city's ability to track
top companies talents
and candidates might not come as long as
state allows companies to use
non-compete
agreements a non-compete is part of an
employment contract where the worker
agrees
they won't take a job as a competitor
and start a rival business for some time
after leaving a company so there's an
issue with that in florida yeah of
course
for non-compete agreements yeah do they
have that in texas they uh
in texas no you're fine in texas but in
california is an issue
it's not an it's not compete right
non-compete is a uh
doesn't have a lot of weight in
california in california no but it
doesn't matter miami it's huge
or florida's huge yeah that's that's
yeah that's the whole point of the story
right so these guys are talking about
that's kind of hurting us you know
all this other stuff so what do you know
about it i know you were just talking to
his camera trying to get uh mayor
francis suarez
uh on the phone this morning he was busy
but i was speaking with his
communications
department he we can get him on when
when we'd like
um a couple different things going on
here number one was the
miami was the number one top city for
small business in 2019
so they've laid the groundwork for being
very small business friendly very
entrepreneur friendly low taxes
you know sunny weather all that going on
mayor francis suarez is leading the
the charge on this um for someone who's
lived and worked in miami i can tell you
the non-compete is a very big deal like
it's i thought that there was sort of a
universal thing but
this is a very florida-centric policy
apparently
and that's something that's going to
have to be rectified if all these
bigwigs and silicon valley type
people are considering moving to florida
and specifically south florida no one's
moving to the panhand
panhandle um but in that tweet i don't
know if we want to pull that up kai if
you have that
he said let's talk let's talk about this
so he's opening this i mean if there's
somebody who is
business friendly entrepreneurial driven
and willing to make it's a wheel and
deal and make business happen it's this
guy right here
francis suarez shout out to you francis
um he said how can i help
um dm me he's sliding his dm i'd be
happy to dme and we'll set it up
so i did not know that this was such a
non-big deal in california it is a big
deal in florida
everyone who's considering moving jobs
asks about it now compete
but in california i guess you can just
kind of come and go as you please we'll
see what they can do i read some of this
thread it's interesting he really does
interact with these tech people in
silicon valley a couple things number
one
if you're super rich at some point you
want to have some fun there is no fun to
be had in silicon valley these guys want
to get the hell out of there they want
the hot chicks
they want to have fun i think that
drives a lot of this i think they're
bored
the other thing is how can not some of
these engineers and really smart tech
people in silicon valley
be a little bit more on the conservative
side than these radical lefts that are
running the
the social media giants out there i mean
at some point you can't agree with
everything that that company does and
you want a fresh start somewhere else
third thing is if there is a serious
issue with the non-compete in florida
ron desantis will fix it i mean that
guy's a smart governor
he's five steps ahead of everybody else
if it means more business for the state
of florida
and in this case a lot more and a lot
more revenue he'll change it watch for
that to be changed in a couple years
yeah i wouldn't be surprised either by
the way he's a guy that's also wanting
to run in the future he's a guy that's
very ambitious to want to run for office
yeah and he's already said i will never
do a lockdown
he's already put forth legislation that
will make it a
huge felony to riot anywhere in florida
as well so look what's happening right
now i've been saying this now for a
while
if california and texas had a baby the
baby's name would be what
florida it's that simple you take the
best of california
you take the best of texas you combine
it to get you got florida
if i was the governor of florida if i
was the governor of florida
i would out recruit the governor of
texas
like never before if i was the governor
of florida i would out recruit
i'm surprised that florida doesn't out
recruit
texas i am so surprised that florida
doesn't outrecruit texas to get the
businesses to move to florida
they have more to offer than texas does
when you think i know a lot of people
disagree with this
but between those two states you got the
top two states competing
nevada's kind of tough yeah nevada's
kind of tough to be recruiting to nevada
i get that it's a good place to be a lot
of californians are going there
but i think florida is going to be
especially with what's going on right
now a lot of these guys going for
because typically california when they
leave they go away they go to nevada
or they go to texas yep new york that
was like sure exactly or arizona
but now cal aloha ohanian is going from
silicon valley think about where silicon
valley is
all the way to the complete corner
that's where they're going they're
changing corners
from one into the other side of the east
coast yeah exactly
do you think part i mean these guys are
smart desantis is smart so is abbott
these are smart governors that know what
they're doing do you think there's a
little bit of them they're thinking
if i recruit too much it could flip my
state a little bit i mean if you look at
arizona
the influx of californians into arizona
has had an impact on how that state
voted but that's a different recruiting
that's a different recruiting than it is
for recruiting like nevada
and recruiting like uh uh like i was
thinking about going to arizona for a
long time so i went to phoenix okay
we when i looked at homes in phoenix
there was a place i don't know what it's
called it's a paradise valley paradise
i talked about it right now no but i
knew that's where you communicate it's
the only place you
we went to this place and by the way no
i mean it's like a
beautiful place you go to this community
you're gonna get a home for like four
million dollars
okay but you get the home for four
they go pick up your groceries for you
you simply call the concierge
you live in a community they go pick up
your groceries for you they have a spa
in the community
they have massages in the community they
have everything in the community so you
and then you have your own house gated
community
gated house in a gated community the
place was beautiful and then i came back
and said why would i go to phoenix
what for what am i going to go there for
if i'm a golfer i get it
if i got something i get it but if i
have a choice between them and nevada
why would i go phoenix over going to
nevada i'm not going to have to pay the
tax if i go to a taxes by going to
nevada so
so what phoenix is attracting is
different
than what nevada's attracting phoenix is
attracting middle
america because it's cheaper to go there
let me go there
what nevada attracted is business owners
by the way the whole tony shea story
like zappos went there
and you know his move was to move zappos
to headquarters being there a lot of
other businesses moved to nevada because
of taxes
this is different phoenix is very
different than nevada texas and
florida quick shout out chris puckett
donated five bucks he says i've worked
for google facebook and yahoo
couldn't have done that with uh with a
ridiculous non-compete silicon valley
would not exist without this so
to eliminate the non-competition exactly
i'm saying it wouldn't it wouldn't
happen you know those those governors
have to be like big-time football
coaches the way they recruit
man just all-out warfare just go for it
good analogy
i actually agree with tom you've used
the word recruit recruit recruit
i mean that's what you do in your
business but i've never really heard
governor's recruiting until i started
you know
hearing you say it so often so i was in
the state of california rick perry was
coming to california recruiting
businesses
rick perry got on the radio saying if
you
run a business in the state of
california yeah and you're sick of the
politics you're sick of the regulation
you're sick of the taxes
call me at this number did that really
yeah
are you kidding well he then we met with
him yeah
we sat down with perry he took us to
rangers game we spent a whole day with
him we spent with time with him and
nolan ryan and don nelson
don ellison's son donnie nelson yeah and
we sat in the box
and perry sat down with my with my wife
jen and talked to him and nolan ryan
jennifer used to play
softball with nolan ryan's daughter so
next thing you know we're sitting there
having a conversation together
then we met with mayor masso of frisco
who was the
the frisco was the fastest growing city
in america it was a three-term
mayor i think he was there for like
eight or twelve years crushing it nine
years right
cowboys have their first that's right
that's right that's right yeah and then
pga moved to frisco by the way pga
headquarters is officially non-frisco
and then we're like wait a minute this
guy's a gr and then when you come here
to visit texas you should have seen how
they treated you they got gifts for our
kids
they knew our kids names every single
thing was
detailed the way they recruited us to
the state of texas
it was beautifully done i think
florida's missing an opportunity
i don't know florida wants all the
businesses to go there
but if they did florida should have 10
more fortune 500 headquarters over there
than they do right now why would you say
that florida wouldn't want the best i
don't know i don't know it's a purple
state why wouldn't you want more people
to want to go there yeah
but i think the emphasis has got to be
on recruiting talent by the way
you know why florida would also be a
great here's what i would focus on if i
was a governor of florida
i would focus on businesses fortune 500
businesses that do a lot of business
with
europe and international well latin
america that's the gateway to latin
america as well what i'm saying is
europe
europe specifically there's a big
difference between being in dallas
to go to london yes than it is to go
from fort lauderdale to go to london
right
that's why you in new york city you go
to where london boom easy flight right
laguardia or john
you know any of those airports you're
going over there okay florida has that
opportunity those types of fortune 500
companies
i'm moving to florida easy boom take a
flight here in europe why wouldn't you
do that so
anyways i think florida's got a big
opportunity for recruiting
uh uh if they capitalize on it but we'll
see what's going on we got a pat
here's an idea we got to look into this
florida thing just we've got to look
into florida it sounds like a nice place
there's a possibility of moving yeah
yeah we got to look into that i would
consider it
yeah uh uh very very seriously
considerably we should look into it i
got a contact i know the challenge with
you is the one challenge we have with
you is
we were talking about this this weekend
adam for whatever reason
is in love with the nightclubs and uh
adam is like the uh
or something when some of these private
jets land that's where you need to be
partying
no we'll we'll you can see me at bodega
or club live in miami that's about it
all right so let's
you think there's an age limit when
you're no longer want to go to
nightclubs i've hit it
going time you hit that like 15 years
ago well i'm older than you so i
probably did hit it 15 years ago
where the thought of going to a
nightclub is just like too much work
adam's the other way around the thought
of
not going to the nine o'clock god i'm
miserable i don't get to a nightclub in
the next year seven days a week is that
enough freak out i'm gonna freak out
adam just likes the idea of walking up
with that gate the velvet rope opening
for him did you say walk in
with the with the hungarian
no he needs a special code word party uh
you know you know how you you know how
you're if you're south beach royalty if
you could walk up and you could be like
hey look at these 25 hungarian guys
they're with me they're going to come
they're going to
adam came in and they come in the club
if you can get a bunch of dudes in the
club adam asked me if you spell orgy
with a y
or an i.e i had to correct him on that
yeah so
but tom knew
tom tried to set me up buddy oh yeah you
wrote that story all right